so you never you never answered earlier
what uh what what anime do you want to
get nominated this year what what did
you put forward for like some of your
favorite anime this year I'm curious for
this season actually um oh for this
season okay um actually that show
started like last week of September so
it can kind of get in oh okay so it's
like I'm kind of I'm be about it because
is it right is it fair with just one
episode with show is is it Alon
it's I love mango fre
oh my God it's on Netflix right no [__]
unfor well I'm not sure Japan might be
on Netflix Japan saw on Netflix yeah cuz
it's on the west it's in crunchy roll so
that's all I know I want I want to see
like how it goes I guess like again like
the first episode was the longest
episode so yeah it was like an hour and
20 minutes I love our first episode
animes just gets you into it yeah I know
cuz you know 20 minutes you just pull
out and you're like a and [__] end it
you didn't say that about
Oceano listen listen I like the first
episode of Oceano after that where it
lost me I thought the first episod of
oce was good and it was boring that was
even a shown on in cinema so wow yeah
yeah so this year I guess so Chains man
Boku is for this year so they
technically is this
year those are big
onu and of course Ooa too you like Ooa
uh I have been reading manga so it's not
there was no surprise for me but I
really like that the ambience and know
the kindfulness the the manga is going
[__] wild Rec the manga recently I'm
just like ain't no way the manga's going
everywhere it is it's like it's losing
focus I think right I thinka Saka is
just like I'm gonna do what the [__] I
it felt like that like two episodes in
it felt
like the beginning it's like this season
is probably F we forgot about the whole
mystery right away we were like all
right guys we're going to ter house now
yeah but like if you read the Manga
recently akasaka has lost his mind like
it's the like I I I like I'm convinced
he's just trolling at this point like he
just does I think he's just trolling we
want to spoil anything but the same time
like oh what happened to this scene what
happened to this relationship and like
wow yeah yeah it gets wild yeah it's not
too bad like I'm a little bit worried
about uh
Kaiju oh yeah kaij is definitely going
down the the PO in the cat for it and
then anime hasn't started yet is the the
giant monster oh yeah 30 something year
the guy who just getting a prime time
after like obvious prime time and he's
like joining this kind of self-defense
Force against uh kaijus he himself
become a Kaiju the concept is kind of
interesting the concept is cool and the
first couple of volumes of the manga
were like really good hook first Arc is
video good yeah and then it's just kind
of slow yeah I agree it's kind of going
down
happens with like so many manga in anime
though the first one's a banger and then
they kind of like all right well [__]
actually manga recently that has in my
opinion just keeps going up is D Don oh
yes that manga is just it the peak is
just keeps peeking the made into yeah I
read that for the first time on stream
the other day and it it is wild it's
[__] insane and to think that that's
his first manga that he's ever made as
well is like crazy yeah it's it's crazy
that we've had Dand and like hell's
Paradise who are both like assistants
from the chainsaw man author like what
was going on in this apartment going in
this
cooking juices just like casually like
just creating prodigies like in in his
office you know we see this uh with
other stuff that's happened though in in
different completely unrelated different
creative Fields across the world I think
when you get like a a really big project
a lot of people worked on it often end
up doing their own really amazing stuff
probably because of the the environment
they learned so many important things
yeah for sure so I can imagine that the
same thing happens with mangas yeah but
I think it's just like it's very rare in
the case of like fujimoto's assistant
like that it's l so far it's literally
been every single one of his assistants
have come out with absolute bangers that
are like unique in their own way like
cuz the problem with like a lot of like
mangas Who start off as assistants of
other mangas is that they tend to kind
of like bite at the ankles of whoever
they were assisting right so like um one
I can think of is like sodachi the of
Gama his assistant uh um the creator of
SK dance yeah was it was the assistant
of witchat right now yeah who's doing
witch watch right whereas like his stuff
is cool but when he first started off
with skar dance it was very obvious that
he took a ton of inspiration from gint
to the point where people were kind of
calling it a gint clone whereas like
fujimoto's assistants they're making
some wild [__] but none of it is really
like attached that much to chainsaw man
or any other of fujimo like just as wild
yeah it's all like wild [__] and I don't
know if that's because they all just
happen to be really wild people or if
that was an influence by Fujimoto cuz my
God he like if you read any interviews
or any stories about him as a person
it's like some of like he sounds like a
maniac of the weirdest [__] I've ever
heard in my life like but you know what
the
author actually turned out to be a
normal guy according
to yeah I I I remember reading the story
about Fujimoto like the author of
Chainsaw man and uh he he was talking
about his childhood or something about
how he had like a childhood like a
goldfish like growing up and he talked
about his his experience when his
goldfish died right and he was like so
sad when he was like burying the
Goldfish and he was like he just never
wanted to part from this goldfish cuz it
was his first pet so he just [__] ate
him that's prob yeah he got the idea of
eating somebody so important to you if
you watch the show
yeah so like when you hear that when you
hear that story right and you're like
okay I can see how that anecdote or that
experience influenced you know some of
the themes in like chainsaw man for
instance right so now when you read the
rest of Chainsaw man or like fire punch
or anything he's made you're just like
what stories behind this how how did you
come up with this
[__] yeah it it makes it made me realize
oh that's why chainsaw man is this way
chainsaw man is like his least weird
work in my like actually one of his
least weird Works might I mean what's
the saying again it's like a a genius is
just an insane person with an
audience he he definitely strides that
line like perfectly I guess look back
was more sane I guess look back was
probably the most sane
one the most saying a lot yeah which is
saying a lot but what's your favorite
mango of all time uh 20th century boys
oh yeah easy which is why I'm really
really looking forward to now sour Pluto
like coming out this that's going to be
sick this I mean yours though is JoJo
right yeah I've read all of Jojo
actually I haven't read uh part eight
yet or nine um because I just didn't get
around to it I don't know why party was
I yeah everyone me everyone I said
party I'm so sad if I get into it I'm
not going to like it right I mean I
really really really like gun a lot oh
cool one of my favorites uh except there
was some weird Parts but it was really
we uh man berserk was also I feel like
berserk is such a cop at answer but it
was just so good I mean yeah I actually
started rereading berserk recently uh
because I had all the physical volumes
in my house in England the fairy [__]
was weird though I'm not going to lie it
was a little weird the fairy [__] yeah
when they just they get to the island
with fairies oh and you're just like man
he played too many Idol
games
oh let him cook though I don't know
maybe we don't he cooked on the arc
afterwards that's fine okay yeah true
you probably read the most amount of
manga I I guess yeah um my alltime
favorite if I had to pick one it'
probably be right pun P for me is a love
hate like I think I think it's an
absolute Masterpiece but I don't enjoy
reading it you know every time I reread
it I think like one where I think it's
like absolutely incredible and I love
rereading it every single time is F of
the ner oh hul is probably my alltime
favorite like I've reread that so many
times and every single time I'm like
damn this thing is so underappreciated
especially in the west like in Japan
it's like a legendary one thing I've
struggled to really um when when people
talk about old manga specifically is
that it's hard to separate the Legacy
from like the actual content and to know
whether people are are talking so fondly
about it because of what it once was or
what it meant at the time says the JoJo
fan yeah
JoJo's great still bro what are you
saying JoJo wouldn't be here if it
wasn't for f of the All Star no no no I
know but like it's like if it's like
when people like uh when they what's a
really old one that people just talk
even it's dog [__] now no I don't know
like when people like what I guess to a
lesser degree it's like everyone I don't
know yeah I guess that's a like I don't
know yeah just Anime that everyone has
watched in Japan
drag ball yeah and then like like Dragon
Ball's one of them where I would say
like Dragon Ball is is spoken about a
lot and it's very iconic but it's hard
to like actually be like all right what
is the actual like content here how do I
like Nostalgia and everything away and
so like H noen has always been one of
those weird ones to me where I'm like
man I want to get into it but it's hard
to look past the way everyone talks
about it it's just more of a like it was
good or the Legacy I mean the memes have
definitely ruined it that's for sure I
meaner [__] know which is only ever
said once in the manga by the way the
only other thing I know about it is that
every godamn Pinko place in Japan is
hton oan which is like which I feel like
makes me not want to watch it because
I'm like why that's how my uncle became
a
fan the Pinko every single Pachinko
place in Japan is is honen and then
there'll be another anime or AA that's
because the age demographic of people
who are going to these Pinko PS Now grew
up reading h you remember the song So
vividly yeah every time you listen to
you are shock like that [__] gets your
blood actually actually so [__]
true watch H or read it um I would read
it yeah reading just a vis is so
sounding it because you are fan of Jojo
I think you appreciate too yeah I think
like the the anime was good like I
enjoyed it and it was it was a good
anime adaptation um but the thing that
really stands out about hulon is just
har tiso the illustrator just his style
it's so
unlike 26 volumes I think I mean if you
can do one I'm like 50 volumes in the
one piece if you can do one piece in
JoJo you can do F isn't one piece long
uh isn't JoJo longer than one piece
yeah's longer than both them well
Becky Becky's just I feels like it feels
like a fan cam for you like it doesn't
feel like a like an actual story it just
feels like a fan-made story about you
yeah pretty much accur also I
[__] memes dude the man this meal is
so good and then it's the the [__]
illusion I love that video become a meme
they're like anime fans eating good and
then it's you making an invisible meal
have you seen this yeah [__] and he
does the invisible table
flip we got him back is in the manga the
sex scene like a first time sex scene
it's just like a fighting scene oh my
God that is my favorite just so funny
and then just Yugo is just [__]
hunched over and just like eat
her John was telling me about the scene
where Yugo has sex with a man but then
apparently the way he justifies it as
not being gay for whatever reason he's
like all other beings are are [__] to
me because I'm yujo yeah yeah yeah and
it's like what like all other creatures
on this planet are below me so I can do
whatever I want what the [__] is
happening what is going on in this
manga she like like if if like one of
those Alpha podcast men had like sex
with man and they were like no I wasn't
gay wasn't gay H it was just I'm so alha
that's another that's just destroyed the
sexuality debate with one
line you ask e how many genders are
there it's just like it's not a question
doesn't matter doesn't matter not going
to be even controversial that's that's
another manga artist that like I just
want to hear like anecdotes from how do
you how do you come up with love to go
for a drink with yeah right just love to
sit down just want to figure out like
how do you just come up [__] yeah insane
funny you mentioned slam dunk earlier
because that's my favorite manga but I
guess like we have I guess in Asia it's
like so Lov it's like it's super loved
it was I was debating between slam donin
Fist and All Star for my favorite it's
like they're both out there for me I I
hope to get get more recognition in the
west and I was hoping that the new movie
was going to do that yeah because it was
like CG even though I've heard it was
like still really really good like if
fan see CG now
like I'm not watching dude in the I I I
go to the cinema a lot in Japan yeah I
swear for like 3 months straight it was
the only thing that was being played
yeah only thing like nothing else was
being played and if it other stuff was
being played it be like nine showings of
Slam dun one showing of John Wick by the
way came out today and like what the
[__] is going on yeah I mean that's
that's the power man of Slam dung is
that like it's even to this day like
people are still rediscovering it like
newer Generations are rediscovering it
because hear from the previous
generations right isn't that that uh the
famous spot where they got to take
pictures from the manga right it's just
it's just there it's just for a picture
yeah apparently that place has been like
they like they' interviewed a bunch of
people recently I saw on Japanese news
they were like yeah we were just we wish
there wasn't so many tourists coming to
this place especially from Korea and
Mainland China and a lot of a lot of I
didn't know this made more money from
the movie there that's crazy it blows my
mind what you count as an old anime
that's a great question um
now cuz if you ask kids today you
recommend them like Spice and Wolf and
they'll be like that's an old show like
we're getting in the old feel in
pre-2000 and then I think pre 90s is pre
90s is where I would I would I would say
it's old like I I realized this the
other day when I was like oh I would
consider like you know to in my mind
anything that's like 10 years or below
can be like That's a classic you know
but to me [__] like G Lagan still feels
recent even though I know it's really
not you know and then recently like
Killa kill just had its 10y year
anniversary I'm just like oh damn my
life man I remember yeah I remember when
that was like the fresh hot I remember
the day that [__] was announced yeah
yeah remember when trigger saved anime
because of kill the kill I do yeah
trigger it still sounds kind of new
but yeah I think back in those days when
everyone just think of animation company
as too Cinema or to too or maybe tatoko
Pro and that's the I guess and that's
it if you can name more than that I
guess that's very new dude I remember
when like you know the the biggest like
Studio back in the day was like JC stuff
like not the biggest well JC stuff and
like uh Studio Dean was really big me
when like I mean they came back with
freerun but I remember when mad house
was like the bar of production IG
production IG was up there are they of
mad house or am I crazy no no there were
separate yeah but people from production
IG started trigger right no no no no no
people from guy started guy started IG
started Studio wits that's it sorry yeah
yeah God I confusing I remember had a
conversation I went for lunch after I
filmed something at Studio trigger and
some of the staff just came and I mean
because obviously in Japan it's so hard
to judge people's age m
man
Asians such a funny out of
context Asians
Asians and I swear this woman uh she
looked like 29 if she told me she was 29
i' believed her and she just casually
goes yeah I remember working on even Gan
I was like huh what she's like what what
are you what you could just say that say
I I remember working on Evangelion or
something I wait so did you find out how
old she was actually I think I I I I
jokingly I was I think it came up we
were talking about ages I think she said
she was 50 something but my God she did
not look 50 oh yeah I would have thought
those anim animator living conditions
would have spedrun aging but apparently
not I yeah no it doesn't because you're
inside the whole time you you don't hit
any of the sun they told me I needed
vitamin D that was I feel like that was
a lie that's not who who's they
people people told me I needed vitamin D
but everyone I know with the best
looking skin never leaves their house
what's up with that oh I I need Vitamin
D I don't know
I feel better with vitamin
D I probably need it I I'm try salty cuz
I have white people's skin that's just
the British mentality you don't [__]
vitamin D you don't get anyland anyway
it's always cloudy jealous of all three
of you with your you're going to have
amazing skin I already look like a like
a basketball that's been used for too
long